Donald Trump has absolutely exploded in
a childish tantrum the likes of which
we've not seen for a while over what is
really a very well done ad that mirrors
the style and format of an old Ronald
Reagan ad but goes right after Trump on
his handling of coronavirus and the
Lincoln project which has created the ad
is paying to run the ad during Tucker
Carlson's program on Fox News they are
claiming that they are going to keep
running these ads as we close in on the
November election now we briefly talked
yesterday about a few tweets that Donald
Trump sent about this and it is an ad by
the Lincoln project the Lincoln project
is an anti-trump super pac George Conway
funded it founded and funded I think it
rightly said and hilariously George
Conway is the husband of Trump's own
advisor Kellyanne Conway I would love to
know what a quiet night at home is like
with them at this point in time but in
any case it goes right after Trump on
coronavirus it's called morning in
America but morning spelled mo you are
an ing let's take a look at the ad
listen to the ad it's just a minute long
there's morning in America today more
than 60,000 Americans have died from a
deadly virus Donald Trump ignored with
the economy in shambles more than 26
million Americans are out of work the
worst economy in decades
Trump bailed out Wall Street but not
Main Street this afternoon millions of
Americans will apply for unemployment
and with their savings run out many are
giving up hope
millions worried that a loved one won't
survive kovat 19
there's mourning in America and under
the leadership of Donald Trump our
country's weaker and sicker and poorer
and now Americans are asking if we have
another four years like this will there
even be an American project which is
responsible for the content of this
advertising so like I said they paid to
run this during Tucker Carlson's show on
Monday night which may be how Donald
Trump first saw it which is just great I
mean you're going right after Trump in
the ad and you're also going right after
Trump by targeting the Fox News audience
and what is good about this ad is that
it gets right at the heart of not just
the lack of empathy of Donald Trump's
response to coronavirus reporting death
numbers when he does as mere curiosity's
essentially but it also goes after
Trump's cronyism it goes after Trump's
indifference it goes after Trump's
inaction and it covers all of it and it
gets to the economic issues as well and
those may well be resonating with
Republicans in the context of who
they're going to vote for in November 60
seconds of a really well done ad and it
has sent Donald Trump into a complete
and total tailspin Trump started with a
series of tweets close to one in the
morning early Tuesday morning where he
wildly attacked George Conway and the
other Republicans that are involved in
this project saying quote
brace yourselves by the way quote a
group of RINO Republicans who failed
badly 12 years ago then again eight
years ago
and then got badly beaten by me a
political first-timer 4 years ago have
copied no imagination the concept of an
ad from Ronald Reagan morning in America
doing everything possible to get even
for all of their many failures
you see these loser types don't care
about 252 new federal judges two great
Supreme Court justices a rebuilt
military a protected second amendment
biggest ever tax and regulation cuts and
much more I didn't use any of them
because they don't know how to win and
their so-called link
project is a disgrace to Honest Abe I
don't know what Kellyanne did to her
deranged loser of a husband moon face by
the way moon face interchangeably a slur
against Asian people Kelly a George
Conway I believe is half Filipino also
just a slur or or an insult for people
with certain medical conditions her
deranged loser of a husband moon face
but it must have been really bad John
Weaver lost big for Kasich to me crazed
Rick Wilson lost for Evan McMuffin
McMullen to me Steve Schmidt and Reed
Galvan lost for John McCain Romney's
campaign manager lost to Big O and
Jennifer horn got thrown out of the New
Hampshire Republican Party they're all
losers but Abe Lincoln Republican is all
smiles okay so that's a mouthful that
was close to 1:00 a.m. Tuesday morning
but it continued yesterday during the
day with Donald Trump then tweeting
quote most of the money raised by the
RINO losers of the so-called Lincoln
project remember RINO means Republican
and named only goes into their own
pockets with what I've done on judges
taxes regulations health care the
military vets choice and protecting our
great Second Amendment they should all
love Trump problem is I beat them all
this is the guy who is close to being
the leader of the free world were it not
for Angela Merkel he probably would be
this guy has access to nukes he has
access to nukes he's in charge of
responding to a hundred-year pandemic
and this is what he's tweeting now
understand the ad is really a parody or
a sort of satirize ation I don't know if
that's word a satirizing of an old
Ronald Reagan ad Trump says that they
are copying it because they don't have
imagination know that this is this is
called satire this is called turning
something around morning in America was
the Reagan ad here is what is being
mimicked this is the original Reagan ad
it's morning again in America
today more men and women will go to work
than ever before in our country's
history
was interest rates at about half the
record highs of 1980 nearly 2000
families today will buy new homes more
than at any time in the past four years
this afternoon 6500 young men and women
will be married and with inflation of
less than half of what it was just four
years ago they can look forward with
confidence to the future it's morning
again in America and under the
leadership of President rate our country
is prouder and stronger and better why
would we ever want to return to where we
were less than four short years ago
[Music]
I find it funny that Trump attacks them
for copying it he doesn't seem to
understand this isn't a lack of
creativity this is taking a well-known
ad that was positive about a president
and tweaking it to expose the horrible
leadership of Donald Trump excellent job
by the Lincoln Project doesn't mean I
agree with them I'm not rehabilitation
the image of whoever right but if they
help us remove Trump for something
better than Trump then that's a good
thing and the next six months are going
to be wild if they keep putting these
ads together we'll have more coverage of
this ad on the David Pakman show
Instagram page at David Pakman show also
this weekend it's happening I am going
to be participating in a transplant of
my tomato sprouts from indoors to
outdoors in my urban garden if you're
looking to follow the adventure follow
me on instagram at david hackman very
serious stuff one of our sponsors is
privacy calm they're giving you five
dollars when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy
dot-com slash Pakman I've been using
privacy for a little over a year now
you've heard me talk about it before
it's a life saver and here's how it
works takes just a couple of minutes to
set up anytime you buy something online
or on the phone instead of actually
using your real credit card number the
privacy app and the browser plugin let
you give each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account without the merchant
ever knowing your real information so
this allows you to keep your banking
information secure but also to take
control of your finances you can create
up to twelve of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them any time you want so when
you do this it means you're not going to
be charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity
private by not telling companies who you
are you're keeping your bank or credit
card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft and it's
free there's no catch whatsoever but if
you want privacy also offers a $10 a
month plan that gives you one percent
cashback and lets you create 36 credit
cards a month and a $25 a month plan
tailored more for small businesses where
you can create 60 card numbers a month
and much more but definitely go ahead
and at least get started with the free
plan you'll protect your financial info
companies can't charge you unexpectedly
and like I said you'll get $5 to spend
when you sign up at privacy calm /
Pakman